buon pomeriggio a tutti voi
ho trascorso gli ultimi 18 anni
giando in giro per il mondo
intervistando più di 1200 artisti grandi
rockstar e musicisti ed è stato grazie
al loro esempio al loro successo che
sono state incoraggiate a scegliere la
strada meno battuta a credere nella
magnificenza presente nella vita di
ognuno di noi ea fare la mia parte per
un mondo migliore affinché la felicità
sia condivisa perché non esistono esseri
umani di serie a ed esseri umani di
serie b
nel 2009 la commissione europea mia
nominata ambasciatrice per un nuovo
protocollo sul clima dedicato ai giovani
europei durante il summit di copenaghen
il coc fifteen ed è stato lì sotto il
cielo terso e progressista danese che ho
capito che era arrivato il momento per
uscire dalla mia zona di comfort volevo
finalmente essere io in prima persona a
provare a fare la differenza
e così atterrando da copenaghen a milano
ho deciso che avrei indetto una piccola
riunione di famiglia
l'ho fatto con mio padre che all'epoca
aveva 79 anni e mio figlio di tre anni e
mezzo e abbiamo deciso che da quel
momento noi avremmo provato a fare parte
della soluzione e non del problema
noi avremmo provato in prima persona a
vedere se è possibile vivendo impattando
il meno possibile sull'ambiente
credetemi non sapevamo davvero da dove
cominciare ma cominciare sotto l'egida
delle 3r di ridurre riusare riciclare ci
sembra un buon inizio
mio padre ha aggiunto una quarta r
quella di riparare e così abbiamo
cominciato abbiamo preso carta e penna
abbiamo scritto i nostri intenti ed
erano innanzitutto non comprare niente
che non fosse veramente necessario poi
bandire dalla nostra vita gli imballaggi
la plastica bere solo acqua dal
rubinetto usare soltanto i mezzi
pubblici o mezzi a propulsione umana
mangiare secondo un regime vegetariano
vegano e ovviamente mangiare secondo la
stagionalità costruirci una compostiera
per rendere terra fertile i nostri
rifiuti e poi volevamo assolutamente
provare se insomma se ce la sentivamo a
staccare il contatore ea vivere così con
il sole in fronte col piccolo sole che
di solito si va da novembre a milano e
abbiamo cominciato
abbiamo pensato che avremmo vissuto così
non più di tre mesi realtà è durato un
anno ed è stato l'anno più formativo
della mia vita credetemi è stato come
andare sull'himalaya per un anno ma
realtà siamo rimasti via a casa nostra
dove eravamo sempre vissuti è mai stato
un viaggio all'interno di noi stessi
all'interno delle nostre abitudini più
radicate all'interno del nostro ruolo di
consumatore non riuscivo a non pensare a
quella frase che avevo letto una volta
su un muro durante la crisi buenos aires
nel 2001 che diceva le cose sono state
create per essere usate le persone per
essere amate oggi amiamo le cose e
usiamo le persone che strana sensazione
abitare in una grande città e non usare
mai la macchina che strana sensazione
abitare in una grande città come milano
e non mettere mai in mano al portafoglio
per giorni per settimane intere delle
volte e che strana sensazione abitare in
una grande città e non andare mai al
supermercato rendersi conto di una cosa
di una cosa fondamentale e cioè che noi
compriamo tonnellate di cose inutili che
siamo circondati da cose inutili e che
ancora peggio a tantissime cose inutili
dedichiamo il nostro tempo è la nostra
passione aspettavamo tutte le settimane
l'approvvigionamento di frutta e verdura
a km zero biodinamica biologica
coltivata con il cuore cereali in chicco
orzo riso integrale pane fatto bene con
il lievito madre e quindi questo
approvvigionamento per noi era veramente
quella cassetta che aspettavamo con
grandissima ansia
secondo la stagionalità ma cosa sapevo
io davvero della stagionalità già allora
non mangiavo carne da 32 anni e da 15
anni ero vegana ma solo siciliana le
melanzane sono nel mio dna quindi ero
convinta che le siciliane dovessero
cucinare le melanzane tutti i mesi
dell'anno perché le melanzane in natura
ci sono tutto l'anno giusto
e invece no le melanzane non ci sono in
natura tutto l'anno e la cosa veramente
incredibile era che chiedevo ai miei
amici i miei cari amici al mio nucleo di
persone quelle più vicine e nessuno
nessuno aveva una risposta per i miei
quesiti
mi si affollavano mille domande nella
testa e dicevo questo prodotto che sto
per comprare da dove arriva chi l'ha
prodotto era felice era triste i suoi
diritti di lavoratore sono stati
rispettati si sentiva depresso mentre
lavorava e perché è un tipico pranzo
domenicale deve fare a meno in media il
giro del mondo due volte prima di
giungere sulle nostre tavole e perché
perché ci ostiniamo a continuare a
chiamare proteine nobili carni straziate
di animali depressi e imbottiti di
antibiotici
nessuno mi sapeva dare delle risposte
potevo soltanto fare una cosa cercare
mela da sola queste risposte
viviamo correndo mangiando tra un
appuntamento ad un altro compriamo
moltissime cose inutili è il più delle
volte facciamo la spesa alle sei di sera
magari parlando al telefono al
supermercato comprando le prime cose che
ci capitano davanti senza essere mai
presenti ai nostri reali bisogni
ecco avevo cominciato a vivere a impatto
zero da poco è una cosa mi era chiara
aveva una grandissima chance una
grandissima chance di essere presente a
me stessa
avevo la grandissima chance di usare il
mio senso di critica
avevo la grandissima chance di scegliere
e questa qualità della scelta in qualche
modo a macchia d'olio si stava
distribuendo in tutta la mia vita
chi lasciava entrare nella mia vita di
quali persone mi circondava e con che
cosa
nutrivo i miei pensieri è il mio cuore
ecco una cosa mi era chiara mi era
chiara che il 90 per cento dei bisogni
che avevo fossero dettati dal marasma
mediatico all'interno del quale ormai
noi viviamo veramente avevo tutti quanti
con i bisogni non comprando niente e non
usando ma il portafogli realmente mi
rendevo conto di cosa veramente avevo
bisogno e non che era un bisogno indotto
da una pubblicità da un'amica che aveva
il rossetto più bello oppure da una cosa
che in quel momento era alla moda e mi
rendevo conto che i nostri frigoriferi
pieni stracolmi di cibo erano davvero il
simbolo di questa nostra vita sempre più
distratta
proprio pigra e sempre più inconsapevole
in qualche modo erano simboleggiavano il
fatto di cui ormai noi siamo pigri
spettatori troppo presto rassegnati ecco
qual era quindi la grande sfida da
cogliere per me quella di operare ancora
una volta il mio senso di critica non
volevo più permettere alla pigrizia alle
abitudini alla cosiddetta mancanza di
tempo di avere la meglio sulle mie
scelte
appena l'autunno ha fatto capolino
abbiamo preso coraggio abbiamo deciso di
staccare il contatore e così abbiamo
fatto
e così abbiamo vissuto a milano senza
luce senza elettricità senza telefonino
senza macchina senza frigorifero e sono
stati investita da un'ondata di silenzio
e di buio che a voi non vi potete
neanche immaginare perché alle quattro
del pomeriggio a milano d'inverno il
primo di novembre è buio se non sa se
non accendete l'elettricità e quando
tornata a casa e sono le quattro prepari
la cena ti metti a chiacchierare con la
tua famiglia perché questa era la cosa
più bella la vicinanza che abbiamo
ripreso perché eravamo tutti nella
stessa stanza illuminata dalle candele e
poi anticamente si illuminava sempre la
stanza della cucina perché comunque con
il fuoco c'era anche calore passavamo
tante ore insieme cucina ma le sei del
pomeriggio avevamo già mangiato avevo
già lavato i piatti e quando tutti i
libri che tenti maldestramente di
leggere sono pieni di cera
a quel punto non hai altro che fare una
cosa a metterti in ascolto di te stessa
e lì mi si è accesa una lampadina a
farlo accendere stata una frase di un
poeta britannico del xviii del xviii
secolo
samuel johnson che diceva chi non bada
ciò che mangia difficilmente baderà a
qualsiasi altra cosa è lì ho capito dove
si stava giocando la partita
lì ho capito qual era il punto focale
vedete io stavo vivendo senza
elettricità senza macchina senza
riscaldamento senza frigorifero tutte
queste azioni hanno un impatto ma non è
nulla ripeto non è
quella paragonato al cibo che noi
decidiamo di scegliere e sapete perché
perché non esiste nessun gesto 3
migliaia di gesti che noi facciamo ogni
giorno che accomuna tutti gli esseri
umani indipendentemente da sesso razza
religione provenienza
mangiare è l'atto più militante politico
nobile civile ed eco sostenibile che
possiamo fare tutto il resto sono balle
noi siamo la prima generazione di adulti
ad aver perso totalmente idea della
filiera alimentare
ho grande nostalgia di mia madre che
appena arrivava la stagione io sono
catanese quindi sono anche fortunata
perché comunque in qualche modo con la
bella stagione le prime fragole
arrivavano prima erano succosa nano
buonissime e le metteva le prime fragole
a tavole ci faceva esprimere un
desiderio
noi abbiamo perso totalmente la
ritualità del t del cibo siamo la prima
generazione di adulti che non ci
rendiamo conto di un interessante
paradosso
noi siamo il 20 per cento della
popolazione mondiale che sfrutta
l'ottanta per cento delle risorse
eppure eppure non pensiamo ad una cosa
siamo sempre più sovralimentati ma
sempre meno nutriti nutriti nel profondo
perché il cibo che mangiamo ci
impoverisce impoverisce questo mondo
depaupera saccheggia e soprattutto non
può creare ricchezza perché uccidere 10
miliardi di esseri senzienti l'anno
soltanto per mangiare noi non potrà mai
creare ricchezza perché non potrà mai
creare una distribuzione equa non
soltanto delle risorse ma soprattutto di
un senso condiviso di felicità le serre
e ignoranti nelle epoche dalle liberi
informazioni è veramente il più grande
danno che noi potremmo infliggere alla
nostra vita ed è ormai necessario
necessario come l'aria che respiriamo
renderci conto che non possiamo più
continuare a vivere distruggendo
depauperando svilendo sprecando abbiamo
diplomi master abbiamo lauree eppure in
quanti di noi sanno quando fiorisce un
broccolo
che senso ha avere queste lauree appesa
al muro quando non sappiamo mai qual è
la stagione giusta per mangiare una
zucchina
eppure noi siamo coloro siamo la prima
generazione che abbiamo gli strumenti
per considerare in che modo il cibo
nutra la parte più fondante di un essere
umano attraverso le nostre scelte
alimentari noi ci impadronì a mo di un
ideale di una passione e permettiamo a
milioni di esseri umani e permettiamo a
milioni di esseri viventi di avere la
vita dignitosa che ognuno di noi merita
l'ottanta per cento della foresta
amazzonica è abbattuto non per fare
posto alle colture di cereali per dare
da mangiare a 12 miliardi di persone
esattamente il doppio di quanto siamo
adesso no ma per dare cibo a quelle
povere bestie svilite nella loro essenza
macchina è geneticamente modificate che
noi abbiamo la pretesa di continuare a
mangiare mangiare è l'unico gesto che si
è compiuto con coscienza può davvero
distribuire le risorse in un modo più
equo
vedete io sono cresciuta a catania
probabilmente sono diventate ecologista
per reazione perché crescere a catania è
più una sfortuna che altro anche perché
catania negli anni 80 non era per niente
una città ecologista come non lo è
adesso e nottetempo passavo notti
insonni da bambina sentire il crepitio
delle fiamme
in quegli anni ripeto catania era
veramente abbandonata erano gli anni
ottanta e ogni tanto questo sentimento
perverso proto ecologista faceva
capolino facendo bruciare i cassonetti
ormai stracolmi di spazzatura
credo che sia stato lì che mi è stato
assolutamente chiaro che ogni nostro
gesto che ogni nostra azione che ogni
nostra acquistano un impatto
sull'ambiente però credetemi
tutto questo è assolutamente vero ma io
ho provato in prima persona vi posso
assicurare che se non ci rendiamo
veramente conto che a fare la
rivoluzione è il cibo che noi mettiamo
nel nostro piatto siamo ancora molto
lontani dalla soluzione
durante quel mio anno di vita a impatto
zero mi piaceva raccontare una favola e
della favola che adesso voglio
raccontare a voi
mio figlio ma la chiedeva tutte le sere
da un momento molto bello ha un
protagonista e questo piccolo colibrì la
foresta va in fiamme e tutti gli animali
sfuggono fuggono guidati dal re della
foresta e cioè il leone a un certo punto
il leone alza la testa e vede un piccolo
colibrì che sta ritornando in
dietro e non capisce cosa sta facendo e
dice piccolo colibrì dove stai andando
il colibrì dice vado a spegnere
l'incendio il leone dice non puoi
spegnere l'incendio se un colibrì può
portare soltanto una goccia di acqua nel
tuo becco e lui dice vado a fare la mia
parte per me è una favola bellissima e
quella che tutte le sere mia consolata
mentre ero lì al buio avevo freddo e
dicevo ma che cosa voglio dimostrare
fondamentalmente non volevo dimostrare
niente a nessuno il contatore era lì
poteva accenderlo in qualsiasi momento
ma uscendo dalla mia zona di comfort e
uscendo da quella zona in cui diamo
troppe cose per scontate
io volevo veramente capire che tipo di
essere umano io fossi che tipo di essere
umano stavo diventando e che tipo di
contributo potevo dare a questo mondo un
anno è passato ho acceso il contatore
ho ricominciato a usare il frigorifero
la macchina quando hanno bisogno
prendere un treno per venire qui con voi
questa sera ma soprattutto ho imparato
la cosa più bella
adesso so quando fiorisce un broccolo
grazie